PROFESSOR: So we have quite a
bit to do in lecture today,
but there are two main things
that are going to happen.
The first is that I finish up
the discussion of Aristotle's
views on happiness and harmony,
and the second is
that I want to introduce
you to the topic of
the disordered soul.
And for the second part
of the lecture, we'll
be using our clickers.
You do want to make sure you
have them out within the next,
I don't know, eight
minutes or so.
So as you may recall, what we
were talking about in the last
lecture was this ancient idea
that there's a certain sort of
thriving that's available
to human beings.
A certain sort of flourishing,
a certain sort of what the
Greeks called eudaimonia,
available to people whose
souls exhibit a certain
kind of harmony.
And you recall that the ancient
picture as articulated
in Plato and taken on in many
ways by Aristotle, was that we
have reason, rationality.
We have spirit, a set of
emotions that are concerned
with things like honor.
And we have appetite, which are
concerned with things like
the consumption of food and the
procreation that allows
our species to continue, and
the procreation that allows
our species to continue and the
procreation for the sake
of doing procreation.
And that the person who is in
a position to thrive or
flourish is the person whose
instinct in the domain of
appetite and in the domain of
emotions are in line with his
or her reflective commitments.
That is, somebody who acts
automatically in the way that
he or she would like to
act reflectively.
The person who instinctively
sits down and does her reading
when she's committed
to do her reading.
The person who instinctively
avoids the chocolate cake when
she's presented with the
chocolate cake, if that's what
she's committed to do.
So what Aristotle tried to
do in the segment of the
Nicomachean Ethics that we read
is to give us a formula,
a strategy, a method, for
getting to the point of having
our soul in order.
And just to remind you where
this fits in the context of
his argument, the claim that
Aristotle makes is that
there's one sort of thing that
we pursue for its own sake,
and it's exactly the thing
that I just referred to.
It's this flourishing
or eudaimonia.
It's this feeling that one
is living up to the
greatest one can be.
And Aristotle points out that
the sort of flourishing that
we're interested in here is
not the gratification that
comes from satisfying one's
lower appetite.
It's not the gratification that
comes from satisfying the
demands that honor or
spirit give us.
But rather, it's the
gratification that comes from
making use of our capacity
as reflective beings.
And you have an argument for
that which I went over at the
end of last lecture, which is
that for each object, there is
something that is special
about it, something with
respect to which it has
properties that the rest of
the objects in the
world don't.
And the special function of a
human being, says Aristotle,
is the expression of reason.
"The soul's activity that
expresses reason," in one of
the standard translations.
So the human good on the
Aristotelian picture has got
to be the thing about human
beings that sets them apart
from other sorts of creatures.
The other sorts of creatures
have the kind of lower
appetites that we've
described.
In fact, almost every biological
being seems to have
something like what Plato would
call an appetitive part
of the soul.
And it appears that a number of
non-human animals also have
what Plato and Aristotle would
call the spirited part of the
soul, at least in some ways.
They have emotional connections
that seem to be
manifest in their behavior.
But the best and most complete
distinctly human virtue, says
Aristotle, is the capacity
to engage in reason.
And the capacity to engage
in reflection.
And the capacity, then, to
structure one's life in such a
way that spirit and appetite
fall into line with reason.
So virtue on Aristotle's picture
is being such that
your instinctive responses
fall into line with your
reflective commitments.
It's being such that what
happens to you in moments
where you're not paying
attention to your behavior is
the sort of behavior that you
would look back on and say,
"Wow, I'm so glad that in the
moment of crisis, what I did
was help that child".
Or, "what I did was avoided
that temptation that would
have led me to do something that
I would have disavowed".
So the question that Aristotle's
concerned with, in
the pages that we read, is a
question of what that virtue
looks like, and how that sort of
virtue might be cultivated.
The virtue, to remind you, is
exactly the virtue that Plato
called the virtue of justice.
It's the virtue of there being
a certain kind of harmony
among what they call the parts
of the soul, and that harmony
being such that it's a harmony
we would reflectively endorse.
Now I'm going to go relatively
quickly through the next two
slides, exactly because we're
going to come back to this
issue in Aristotle
two more times in
the next three lectures.
In lots of ways, this unit of
the course is going to attempt
to provide an exposition of
Aristotle's insights.
This is attempt number one to
introduce it to you, and
you're going to get
it twice more.
Aristotle distinguishes between
two kinds of virtue:
there's virtues of thought
and virtues of character.
Virtues of thought are things
that grow through
straightforward pedagogical
instruction.
So it's a virtue of thought
to know that six
times seven is forty-two.
It's a virtue of thought to know
facts about the periodic
table, or to know information of
a particular kind about the
political structures
around you.
Those are virtues of thought,
and the way that virtues of
thought are communicated to
others and cultivated in
others is through a process
of traditional pedagogy.
But one of the crucial themes
of the ancient philosophical
tradition is that in addition
to virtues of thought, there
are what Aristotle called
virtues of character.
Virtues of character aren't
things that you process
rationally and come to acquire
as the result of somebody
telling them to you.
They are things that you process
in the spirited and
appetitive parts of your soul
as the result of a kind of
cultivation of habit.
Aristotle says of these virtues
of character that they
arise in us neither by nature
nor against nature.
What does he mean by that?
Well, suppose I was trying to
train my glasses to stay in
the air when I let go of them.
Would I have much success?
I could keep rewarding them
every time they stay in the
air, and I'll scold them every
time they fall on the ground.
No matter how many times I try
to train my glasses to stay in
the air, they will fall
to the ground.
It is against their nature.
It is impossible to change the
relationship between my
glasses and the gravitational
force in the world.
Aristotle makes the point
speaking of a stone.
It's impossible to change the
character of the glasses.
By contrast, if I take a pumpkin
seed, and I put it in
some soil, and I put water in
it, and I put it out in the
sunshine, then even with no
intervention on my part, the
pumpkin seed will give rise to
a pumpkin sprout that will
come out of the soil and move
towards the sunlight in such a
way that eventually it will
form a pumpkin plant.
So if I plant the pumpkin seed,
then by nature, it will
become, without my intervention,
a pumpkin plant.
Virtues of character lie in
between what a pumpkin seed
does for a pumpkin plant and
what trying to train you
glasses does, given gravity.
They arise in us neither
by nature--
they don't grow out of us
naturally in the way that our
height grows out of us
naturally, or our hair grows
out of us naturally.
Those are things that happen in
the due course of things.
Nor are they against nature.
They aren't like training
ourselves to be able to float
in the air, or to be able to
stay up for seventy-two weeks
at a time with no sleep, or to
do with no food for a decade.
Those would be things that
are against nature.
"Virtues of character arise in
us neither by nature nor
against nature.
Rather, we are by nature
able to acquire them.
They are things for which
we have the capacity.
And they are completed
in us through habit."
So what does this process of
habituation look like?
Well, Aristotle points out in
one of the most famous quotes
in the Nicomachean Ethics
that we learn to do
things by doing them.
"We learn a craft," says
Aristotle, "by producing the
same product that we must
produce when we
have learned it.
We learn to be a
builder"-- how?
By reading a book called
How to Build a House?
I read something called "How
to Put Together a Table" by
IKEA, and it did not
result in a table.
What resulted in a table was my
excellent twelve-year-old
son, who obviously is a builder
innately, coming and
showing me how to put
together the table.
I thereby learned
to be a builder.
I become a builder by
practicing the art of building.
I become a harpist by
practicing the art
of playing the harp.
How many of you play a
musical instrument?
How many of you learned to play
a musical instrument by
reading a book called, How to
Play the Piano, but never
touched any of the keyboard?
Zero?
OK.
How many of you learned to play
a musical instrument by
practicing the musical
instrument?
How many of you learned to
become a pianist or harpist or
flautist by playing the piano
or harp or flute?
All right.
So Aristotle's point is that the
way we become that which
we hope to be is acting like
that was what we already were.
In the same way as we learn to
play the piano by playing the
piano, we learn to be just
by doing just actions.
We learn to be temperate by
acting in temperate ways.
We learn to be brave by
doing brave actions.
The way that we cultivate habits
is first by consciously
structuring our lives in such
a way that the habit that we
wish to cultivate becomes part
of our behavioral repertoire,
and then doing it over and over
again until it doesn't
require our concentration
anymore.
It's exactly like any habitual
skill you have ever acquired
in the domain of music, in the
domain of sports, in any
domain where you have first
consciously, and subsequently
instinctively, learned to
practice a particular pattern
of behavior, you have performed
the program that
Aristotle describes for the
cultivation of virtue.
So we'll come back to this again
in a couple of lectures.
I want to conclude this section
by bringing out to you
one of the most famous parts of
the section of Aristotle's
discussion.
So Aristotle points out that
there's a danger here.
There's a danger to learning
to play the piano badly,
because the habits that you
cultivate when you keep your
fingers flat instead of curved
are habits that ingrain
themselves in your behavior
in the same way
that good habits do.
It's not as if we have an
automatic filtering mechanism
for practice that says, "oh,
when I practice, only the good
habits will stick, and the bad
habits won't." Whatever it is
that you practice doing will
become habitual to you.
These actions, these actions of
practicing what you aim to
become, "are the sources and
causes both of the emergence
and cause of virtue and of their
ruin." Practicing brave,
you'll become brave. Practice,
in the same context, being
cowardly, and the cowardice will
instill itself in your
habitual behavior
in the same way.
So, says Aristotle, for each
of these states, we need to
attend to the fact that it is
possible to do what we're
aiming for either too much or
too little, and aim for what
is famously called the
Aristotelian middle way.
The virtues of Aristotle, she
says, tend to be ruined by
excess and deficiency.
So suppose you are confronted
with a risky situation.
There are two false
extremes that you
could be drawn towards.
You could respond to it in a way
that is cowardly, or you
could respond to it in a
way that is reckless.
Between these extremes,
says Aristotle, lies
the virtue of bravery.
Suppose you are presented
with a social situation.
You could respond to
it with hostility.
You could respond to it
by being ingratiating.
Between these, says Aristotle,
lies the virtue of
friendliness.
Suppose you are confronted
with a situation where
something is being
asked of you.
You could be stingy.
You could be ostentatious
in what you do.
Or you could be, in the
wonderful translation that we
have in the Irwin,
"magnificent." That which lies
between stinginess and
ostentatiousness.
Suppose you are studying for the
SAT and you're confronted
with a situation where
you can be either
pusillanimous--or vain.
What would fall between them?
Between them falls the virtue
of magnanimity.
Suppose you're confronted with
a situation where the
possibility is to be either
self-deprecating or boastful.
Neither is what's called for.
What's called for is the
truthfulness that
lies between them.
Suppose you're presented
with a joke.
You can be either dour--or
buffoonish.
Or instead, you can be witty.
You might be quarrelsome.
You might be ingratiating,
again, or, between them, you
might be friendly.
Huh.
There I have that twice.
The general principle here is
that there are, with respect
to each of the Aristotelian
virtues, two extremes.
An extreme of deficiency and
an extreme of excess.
And between them lies what
is famously called the
Aristotelian mean.
So you remember when I showed
you that famous Raphael
painting from the wall, "The
School of Athens," where Plato
is pointing to the sky,
referring to the forms, and
Aristotle's hand is in
the middle of his
body, facing flat?
And I said to you, there's two
ways that that has been
interpreted.
One is with respect to
Aristotle's rejection of
Plato's idea of the forms, and
the second, I said, is that
it's sometimes read as a sort
of embodied articulation of
Aristotle's idea of the mean.
So here, for your pleasure, is
Again, we'll come back to
this in two lectures.
Let me close this section by
quoting for you Aristotle's
picture of the virtuous circle
of habit formation.
And right after this is when
we're going to need our
clickers, so if you don't have
them out yet, you should take
them out now.
"Abstaining from pleasures,"
says Aristotle "makes us
become temperate." And once we
have become temperate, we're
more capable of abstaining
from pleasure.
It is similar with bravery.
Habituation in standing firm
in frightening situations
makes us become brave. And once
we have become brave, we
are more capable of
standing firm.
There is a circle to this kind
of practiced behavior.
And what we will read three
classes from now is a
contemporary articulation of
this idea in the form of
something called cognitive
behavioral therapy.
OK.
So that closes what
we were taking
from last week's lecture.
And what I want to open with
and cover in the last
twenty-five minutes or
so that we have is
the topic for today.
So let me just give you the
punch line right now.
The punch line is this.
You remember from the opening
pages of book two of Plato's
Republic that the character
Glaucon poses a challenge to
Plato's character Socrates in
the form of the claim that
behaving justly, behaving in
accord with one's reflective
commitment, behaving in accord
with the norms of morality, is
something that we do only for
instrumental reasons.
There is nothing intrinsically
valuable to the ordered soul.
Today's lecture is about
two incredible stories.
One, the Iliad and the Vietnam
war, as read through the
writings of Jonathan Shay,
two, the experiments of
Stanley Milgram, done here on
this campus in the 1960s, both
of which give us a window into
what human experience looks
like in Glaucon's dream world.
Glaucon said: What we want is to
be able to run wild with no
consequences to our actions.
What we want is to be able to
violate the norms of morality.
Given the chance, anybody
would do that.
The stories that Shay and
Milgram tell us, the
descriptions they give of what
human experience is like in
these moments where the soul
runs amok, suggests that maybe
Glaucon is wrong.
It suggests that for whatever
reason, there appears to be,
at least in these domains, a
need on the part of human
beings for a certain kind
of structure and order.
And in the absence of that kind
of structure and order,
the world seems to fall apart.
What I want to start by doing
in this lecture, however, is
by pointing out to you what an
unusual time you live in.
So could you answer
this question?
Press one if you have served
in the military, two if you
have not served in the military
but you plan or
expect to serve in the military,
and three, if you
have not served in the military,
and you do not plan
or expect to serve.
So one if you have been in the
military, either in the U.S.,
or some other country of which
you're a citizen, two if your
plan is at some point in the
near future, to enroll in
active military service,
and three, if you have
no plans to do so.
OK.
So let's take a, the
numbers on this--
OK.
So it looks like 1% of you have
served in the military.
5% of you have the plan to do
so, and 94% of you have no
expectations that military
service is something that you
will ever do.
Next question.
Think of the person you know
to whom you are closest who
served in the military, and
let me know whether that's
somebody extremely close, a
sibling or a best friend.
If so, push one.
Somebody relatively close, like
your first cousin or a
school buddy, somebody that you
are on a team with, that
you feel relatively close to.
Or three if the closest person
you know who served in the
military is like a kid from your
school, or a neighbor, or
somebody that you don't
know very well.
And let's see how the numbers
come out on this.
OK.
So almost none of you have a
sibling or best friend who is
in the military.
Roughly half of you know
somebody reasonably well who
is in service, and fully a third
of you have no one in
your immediate social
circle who has
performed military service.
Let's go back a generation.
I'm asking you about your
father because we
need a one to one.
If I ask you about both parents,
we'd be doubling the
sampling set.
So of your father, please answer
one if he served in the
military, two if he didn't.
OK.
And let's look at the
numbers here.
So you look different
from your father.
About 5% of you have served
or are planning to
serve in the military.
About 20% of your fathers did.
Let's go back another
generation.
Paternal grandfather, again,
because we need one person.
One if he served in the
military, two if he did not.
Paternal grandfather.
That's your father's father.
Did he serve in the military?
OK.
54% of your grandfathers
served in the military.
So we went from 4% in your
generation, 20% in your
father's generation, 55% in your
grandfather's generation.
You are living in an
extraordinarily unusual time.
The social distance between
American elite universities
and the U.S. military is greater
now than it has ever
been in the 200 years of
this country's history.
And the architecture that
surrounds you gives lived
voice to the way in which your
experience is unusual.
How many of you recognize
this building?
It's about twenty
feet from here.
Every single hand in this
room should be going up.
How many of you have looked
closely at what that is?
So this building, as some of you
know, those of you who are
Yale tour guides certainly
know, is Memorial Hall.
It was built in 1901 without
this facade here.
And at the conclusion of the
First World War, during which
a huge number of Yale associates
died, this addition
was constructed.
Across the top are the names of
battles of the First World
War at which Yale men died.
And down below is an empty
coffin, "In Memory of the Men
of Yale who true to Her
Traditions gave their Lives
that Freedom might not perish
from the Earth."
Yale's relation to World War
I was an extraordinary one.
Here's a passage from a speech
given by Henry Simpson at the
dedication of the war
memorials that
I just showed you.
"After our entry into the war,
and a wide adoption by the
government of the principle
of universal service, Yale
gradually became a military
training camp and a completely
militarized university.
Her faculties and laboratories
turned their resources
entirely over to the arts of
war, and nearly all of her
remaining scholars became
student members of the
Organized Military Forces
of the United States.
Yale maintained one
of the foremost
artillery schools in America.
She carried on a large naval
training unit, commissioned
officers for the Navy.
She trained officers for
the signal corps.
Her chemists conducted resources
for the chemical
warfare service.
Doctors and assistants were
prepared there for the army
hospitals, and a complete army
hospital unit was maintained
by the University in France.
Practically the entire momentum
of this institution
of learning was thrown
effectively into the scales of
war."
The relation between elite
universities and the military
doing both the First and
Second World Wars was
strikingly different than
anything any of you have
encountered now.
And in an effort to memorialize
the contributions
to the war effort made by the
men of Yale, it was decided
that along the interior walls
of Memorial Hall would be
engraved plaques.
So if you walk in on your way to
commons, on your right hand
side as you enter, you see the
names of Yale men who died in
the revolutionary war.
And on the two sides that you
pass, those who died on either
side in the Civil War, the names
of those who died in the
Spanish-American War, the 227
names of those who died in the
first World War, the 514 names
of those who died in the
second World War, the 22 names
Korean War, and the 37 names
of those who died in the
Vietnam War.
Now, the question of why the
relation between elite
institutions and the military
came to be what it is today is
one whose answer depends upon
a number of these incredibly
important and complicated facts
about U.S. history.
Suffice it to say that it was
the view of the majority of
Yale students and a good
proportion of Yale faculty
that the war in Vietnam well
was an unjust war.
And it was for that reason
that there was an
unwillingness on the part of
many of them to serve, and
indeed, a brave expression of
opposition on the part of some
of them that had direct
consequences in their lives.
But the attitude of the Yale
campus towards the Vietnam War
is perhaps best captured by
this image of protesters
co-opting this image of
something used for
commemoration of those who
fought in a just war, and
using it as a way off expressing
their views that
the particular war they
confronted in Vietnam was an
unjust one.
For those of you who have not
yet been convinced that
philosophy is something that
matters: this was a
philosophical debate
about the nature of
what justice permits.
Regardless of whether Yale
students went to fight in the
Vietnam War, a huge number of
other citizens of the United
States went to fight
in the Vietnam War.
And the work which we read for
today by Jonathan Shay is an
incredibly powerful reading
of their experience that
juxtaposes for you quotations
from the great ancient
description of the subjective
experience of war--the
founding text, in many ways,
of the Western literary
tradition, Homer's IIliad --and
the in-their-own-voice
experience of the Vietnam
veterans with whom Jonathan
Shay worked in an effort to help
them deal with the stress
and the trauma that the war
experience produced in them.
And Shay's thesis in this book,
as you know, is that
when a leader destroys the
legitimacy of the army's moral
order by betraying what he calls
themis, what right, the
order of things, the structure
by which we can understand the
world as predictable and
well-ordered--in so doing,
injuries are inflicted on
the soldiers that are
not physical injuries.
They are what Shay calls
moral injuries.
And these moral injuries arise,
he suggests, both in
the Iliad, where Homer describes
the immediate and
devastating consequences on
Achilles, first of the feeling
of injustice at having had his
war prize taken away from him,
and then through what Shay calls
the berserk behavior
that results as the consequence
of the death of
his friend Patroclus.
Now let me pause and say that
in talking about this, we're
glossing over many, many things
that are problematic
about that story.
What is it that Achilles
is upset about?
He's upset about the woman who
was given to him as a prize
for battle being taken
away from him and
given to another man.
I take it that, for most of you,
your conception of what
the moral order permits
does not include war
prizes of that form.
And we'll talk more about
that when we get
to the ethics section.
How do we make sense of moral
standards that are treated as
legitimate in one domain,
and not in the other?
But for the time being, I would
like you to bracket
here, as we bracketed in the
context of most of the ancient
texts that we've been reading,
that which you find
unfamiliar, and focus instead
on what you find familiar.
The description of Achilles'
experience is
one that rings true.
And it rings true in the same
way that the description of
the Vietnam soldier's experience
rings true.
Shay points out that just as
the Iliad is a story of the
devastating consequences for
Achilles and the other
soldiers, so, too, are the
narratives that the Vietnam
soldiers provide an instance of
something that forces us to
see that the consequences go
beyond, and here's a quote
from the Iliad, "the war's loss
upon bitter loss, leaving
so many dead men," --that the
consequence is to taint the
lives of those who survive it.
One of the greatest harms that
the Vietnam War appears to
have done to a good portion
of those who served there,
whether voluntarily or
involuntarily, is to have
produced in them a set
of symptoms that some
psychiatrists find helpful to
describe as post-traumatic
stress disorder.
And these are symptoms that
affect the soldiers, the
survivors of trauma,
in three domains.
They affect their actions in the
world, they affect their
perceptions of the world, and
they affect their social
experiences.
So one of the symptoms of
post-traumatic stress disorder
is "a persistent mobilization
of the body and mind toward
lethal danger, a potential for
explosive violence, as the
result of being constantly on
alert." All of you know the
experience of being in full
focus when you feel yourself
to be in danger.
It's something that occupies
a huge percentage
of the body's resources.
Everything goes on focusing on
being hair-trigger responses.
And you can have this in
all sorts of domains.
You can have it if you're
engaged in video game which
requires you to do an incredibly
quick response, or
if you feel yourself in some
kind of threat situation: But
it's in a full-body experience
of being related to the world
in a particular way.
Now imagine being on alert
in that way all the time.
One consequence of being on
alert in that way is that one
perceives things in the most
negative light possible.
If you are what's sometimes
called risk-averse, then you
are going to, for each encounter
you have, entertain
the possibility that what
you confront is
the worst-case scenario.
And soldiers who are suffering
from post-traumatic stress
disorder perceive those things
around them through the
heightened attentional
mechanisms that come with this
hair-trigger action, and view
them as potential dangers.
And the things that they pursue
as potential dangers
are not merely mundane objects
in the world, like an object
lying on a table that might
ambiguously be either a gun or
an innocent piece of cardboard,
but also in their
social interactions.
And perhaps the greatest cost,
and we'll see why this is such
a cost in Thursday afternoon's
lecture, perhaps the greatest
cost is the loss of the
possibility of social trust.
And I want to point out to you
the way in which this can
happen to cultures as a whole.
Communities that find themselves
subject to certain
kinds of terrorist or guerrilla
warfare by those who
are opposed to them lose the
capacity to behave humanely
towards those with whom
they struggle.
If your opponent's strategy is
to bring bombs into your
country using ambulances, then
you will be forced to treat
ambulances as suspicious
objects.
If, as Shay describes in
Achilles in Vietnam, a common
strategy is to put a baby atop a
pile of explosives, then you
will be forced, through your
enemy's actions, not to help a
needing child.
Robbing your enemy of this
capacity to behave humanely to
you is a strategy that
produces a cycle
of incredible disorder.
Because, of course, it's only
a feeling of being cornered
with nothing else to do that
would lead somebody to take
the strategy of using
ambulances to carry
bombs and so on.
The orderliness that governs
conventional warfare is a
reflection of a certain kind
of psychological need.
And the disorderliness that is
typical of nonconventional
warfare, of which Vietnam is an
example and terrorism is a
second, is something that you
produces in societies as a
whole some kind of approximation
of the
post-traumatic stress
disorder that Shay
identifies in the soldier.
So what I want to do now, in the
last five minutes of the
lecture, is to give you two
examples from Shay of the
phenomenon that he's describing,
and then connect
it back to Glaucon's
challenge.
So the Iliad is a tale
of mania, of anger.
And the opening passage, which
Shay cites, from book one of
which I had you read for today,
is an expression of the
indignant rage felt by Achilles
at the betrayal of
the rules of honor of warfare.
And Achilles says--
this is actually a quote from
book sixteen, but it's talking
about the earlier moment.
"Only this bitterness eats at
my heart when one man has
deprived and shamed his
equal, taking back his
prize by abuse of power.
The girl whom the Akhaians
chose for me I
won by my own spear.
A town with walls I stormed
and sacked for her, then
Agamemnon stole her back out
of my hands as though I was
some vagabond held cheap."
It's a violation of
the honor code.
It's a violation of the rules
and expectations with which
Achilles entered this war. "A
town with walls I stormed and
sacked for her.
I am deprived of her not by the
rules of war but by abuse
of power." Here's a soldier in
Vietnam expressing much the
same thing.
"Walking point"--
which is a job that involves
basically being placed in the
line of soldiers that's most
likely to lead to your being
killed through an explosive--
"Walking point was an extremely
dangerous job.
The decision of who was going to
do it was made not fairly.
It was made politically.
Certain people got the shift.
Certain people didn't.
Certain people on the right
side of certain people."
And this idea that the
distribution of dangers
doesn't track rules, it tracks
whims, is disordering.
So the result of this, and I
talked about this in the last
slide already, is a kind of loss
of trust, a recognition
that ordinary objects-- that's
the story of the baby on the
mine --holds a potential for
danger, nothing is what it
seems, all certainties
liquefy.
And the second discovery that
Vietnam soldiers found
themselves making was something
that we'll discuss
in the context of a paper that
we'll read called "Moral
Luck." A discovery of what
one is capable of in
circumstances.
Here's the veteran: "It's
unbelievable what humans can
do to each other.
I never, in a million year,
thought I would be capable of
doing that.
Never, never, never."
So here's Shay's, here's Homer's
answer to Glaucon.
Dear Glaucon, Please note.
The concern that these soldiers
are expressing is not
about what they seem to be.
It's not about what they are
perceived to have done.
Indeed, one of their complaints
is that when they
come home, no one will listen
to their stories.
The concerns of these soldiers
is about what they have done,
about the being and
not the seeming.
And it is the being, what you
are, what is intrinsically the
case, that is of concern
to them.
So we'll take up this issue at
the beginning of next lecture
with the discussion of the
Milgram, and then we'll turn
to the readings from Epictetus
and the contemporary
analogues of it.